Wuhan China where the virus began
reported no new cases on Monday its
seventh day in a row and nationwide all
the new cases reported were imported but
the World Health Organization warns even
for countries where the cases seem to be
tapering off this is not the time to let
their guard down it's Regional Director
for western Pacific Takeshi Kasai says
countries will have to adopt multiple
approaches testing isolating and
physical distancing to slow the spread
of the virus even with all of these
measures the risk will no will not go
away as long as the pandemic continues
louder these measures can buy as
valuable time to prepare for large-scale
community transmission more countries
are tightening restrictions Japan has
urged its citizens not to travel to 73
countries and regions or a third of all
countries in the world cases there have
topped 2,000 with two clusters emerging
in Tokyo over the past week last week
China banned foreigners from entering
the country after seeing a rise in
imported cases in Hong Kong residents
who've returned from abroad are
monitored to ensure they don't break
quarantine rules the mobile app sends me
notifications occasionally and asks me
to take a photo of my arm with the
wristband at my home but I have no idea
if anyone is really checking my response
Malaysia which imposed strict measures
on movement and closed its borders to
foreigners two weeks ago will now
require returning citizens to be
quarantined at government centers
instead of at home New Zealand has
extended a national state of emergency
for another seven days to provide the
government powers and resources it needs
to prevent the spread of corona virus
Indonesia says it will ban all arrivals
and transit by foreigners as the number
of cases and deaths rise no one knows
how long the pandemic will last but even
after it's over its impact will be felt
for a long time the World Bank's worst
case scenario estimates 11 million
people in the region could be forced
into poverty
Florence Lee al-jazeera well let's get
the latest on developments across Asia
Katrina Yu is live in Beijing for us
Katrina China where you are is obviously
very keen to get its economy back on
track but it doesn't seem very likely or
for the rest of the region reeling
that's right it's going to be a struggle
according to the World Bank across the
East Asian Pacific region it says that
this pandemic has caused an
unprecedented shock to these economies
and to demonstrate the scale of this
impact we've received some figures from
them so last year China's GDP growth was
6.1 percent according to official
figures but the World Bank says this
year because of the outbreak that will
be carved and more than halved to two
point three percent and a worst-case
scenario is that that growth could slow
by as little as 0.1 percent and for the
rest of the region it was five point
eight percent last year and this year it
will be two point one percent according
to the World Bank and potentially even
slower to minus minus half a percent and
equally when it comes to poverty as we
heard in that package previously
millions could be plunged into poverty
before the pandemic 35 million people
were expected to be lifted out of
poverty because of it 24 million at
least will stay in poverty and an
additional 11 million could be plunged
into poverty and this is really bad news
for China because this was supposed to
be a banner year for the Chinese
government 2020 was a year that they
promised to eliminate poverty from the
entire country that's people living on
less than $5 50 a day and according to
official figures they had been making
great strides in 2012 there were 100
million people also living in poverty in
China and last year they were if that
number was about 6 million but now
analysts say because of this outbreak
that target will be impossible to meet
for China because this outbreak has had
a devastating impact on China's economy
we know in February the country was
brought to a standstill and
manufacturing activity contracted for
the first time in 30 years but of course
there are other countries in this region
which are even more vulnerable to the
economic impact of this pandemic and
particularly countries which rely on
tourism for example
we'll rely on trade countries which have
an informal workforce and also countries
which are heavenly indebted so the World
Bank says for those countries the best
thing to do would be really to hunker
down invest in health care as well as
put into place and targeted stimulus
measures such as paying for people's
sick leave Katrina you there for us in
Beijing Thank You Katrina